last time we talked about probability as
an introduction on how to model
uncertainty state estimation is one of
the ways that we can deal with
uncertainty in our system we can take a
model that we don't completely
understand and attempt to infer
information about it based on the things
that we can observe about that
particular system in particular we're
going to look at a set of observations
and actions that either our system takes
or that we observe about the system and
that we take on that particular system
if we continue this process for multiple
time steps then we can continue to
attempt to learn things about the
particular system the process of
completing that behavior over multiple
time steps while making those inferences
is what we refer to when we talk about
state estimation first off state
estimation is a process that's completed
as a consequence of wanting to
understand a stochastic state machine
state estimation itself is not a
stochastic state machine state
estimation attempts to take a stochastic
state machine make a model of that
stochastic state machine and then run
state estimation on it iteratively to
attempt to figure out or recursively an
attempt to figure out what's going on
inside that sarcastic state machine when
you build a stochastic state machine
model there are three components that
are that need to be specified the first
is the starting distribution over States
for instance let's say that I'm trying
to figure out I you know I believe that
I'm sick and I'm trying to figure out
you know what it is that I am sick with
and I could be sick with three things as
far as I'm concerned I could be sick
with strep or I could be sick with some
other more boring virus or I could be
sick with mononucleosis the starting
distribution refers to my starting
belief as to those systems and if I'm
generically sick then and in the general
sense one of the assumptions that
frequently made with respect to starting
distributions is that they're uniform
right it could be equally any of these
things the second thing you need to
specify when you're talking about
modeling a stochastic state machine
is your observation distribution or what
is the likelihood associated with making
a get making a particular observation
given that you're in a current state for
instance if I had mononucleosis how
likely it would it be that I observe a
bunch of white ugly patches on the back
of my throat or if I just had if I had
strapped you know what is the likelihood
associated with that that kind of thing
typically this observation variable is
factored into a couple different
phenomena in the sick example the best
thing to talk about is symptoms right
you know and my lethargic do I have the
white spots in the back of my throat do
I have a fever that sort of thing the
last thing that you need to specify when
you're talking about modeling a
stochastic state machine in your
transition distribution you assume that
your state machine is going to change
over time or it is likely that I will
get more or less sick and there are
things that I can do to induce that kind
of change or there are things that I can
do that effectively model the passage of
time your actions for a stochastic state
machine model can either be actions that
the model takes and you are exclusively
doing observations but one of the
particular observations that you do also
qualifies as an action or something that
indicates the passage of time or actions
can be something that you do to a
particular state in the sick example
things I could do to myself to try to
make myself feel better or at least
figure out better what is going on or
what what my actual you know caused my
distribution to sway towards one
particular state I could take
antibiotics or sleep in and drink a lot
of orange juice or continue my day as
normal given a particular action and a
particular state that you're starting
from your transition distribution tells
you the likelihood associated with being
in a new particular state so as a
consequence of making those actions does
the distribution of likelihood of a
particular illness change
at this point I'm going to walk through
a step of state estimation each step of
state estimation is the same in fact if
you complete multiple steps based on the
information that you gained from the
previous step that's referred to as
recursive state estimation and I'll keep
walking through the SiC example so when
you're doing state estimation you're
trying to figure out something about a
system that you cannot perfectly model
for instance either your own immune
system or your own susceptibility to a
particular disease and you have all the
components that you have a 4-year
stochastic state machine model as a
consequence of the passage of time or as
a consequence of making an observation
and either observing an action taken by
your stochastic state machine or
performing an action behind be upon your
stochastic state machine you're going to
make a new you're going to make a new
estimation of what you believe the
current state of that unknown system or
system that is not completely observable
to you you're going to make a new yeah
you're going to make a new estimate of
your belief of the state of that's
in short you're going to solve for the
probability distribution over s of t
plus 1 there are two steps the first
step is referred to as the Bayesian
reasoning step and it involves
performing base evidence or Bayes rule
upon the current state distribution
given a particular observation so at
this point I've made some sort of
observation about myself if I'm talking
about the SiC model right I spent all
day coughing or I have a fever or my
throat is sore or I feel extremely
lethargic right given that observation I
can take the P of O given s from my
observation distribution multiply it by
my current understanding of the state
distribution and the divide out by P of
O the slowest way to complete this
action is to build the joint
distribution and then condition on a
particular column it's very proper but
you can save yourself some cycles by
doing this let's say I started off with
the uniform distribution right it could
be equally likely that I have strep or a
normal virus or mono as a consequence of
making the observation that I don't have
white spots on the back of my throat
I could say oh the likelihood of me
being in that state is more the
likelihood of me just having a normal
virus is higher and the likelihood of me
having either strep throat or mono is
lower this step takes P of s and
multiplies it by P of O given s once I
have these values I have to scope back
out to the universe or I have to
normalize these values such that they
sum to one that's where I get my PS of T
given L at this point I've accounted for
the observation that I've made but I
haven't accounted for the action on the
system that's the next step we're going
to take our results of Bayesian
reasoning which are sometimes referred
to as B prime s of T and take the action
and find the distribution over States as
a consequence of a single time step or a
single iteration of state estimation the
second step is referred to as a
transition update
we've got our updated belief we're going
to take our transition distribution or
our specification for what happens given
given that we're in a current state and
an action has been taken at that point
we'll have a probability distribution
over the new States and here are my
values from the first step as an example
let's say that I sleep in and drink a
lot of orange juice as a consequence of
sleeping in and drinking a lot of orange
juice there's some amount of likelihood
that I'll remain that I will either
continue to be sick with strep or it's
possible that I actually have just a
normal virus if I have a normal virus
and I sleep in and drink a lot of orange
juice hmm this causality sounds
backwards but it's as a consequence of
not being able to make perfect
observations on the system
if I have an amount of belief that says
that I think I have strep and I sleep in
and drink a lot of orange juice then
it's equally likely that I will have
either strep or a normal virus after
completing that step right
it doesn't differentiate between the two
if I'm sick with the virus and I sleep
in and drink a lot of orange juice then
the thing that I'm going to encourage
myself the state that I'm going to
encourage myself to be in is I have a
virus if I have mono and I sleep in and
drink a lot of orange juice then there's
some likelihood on the next day that I
will still be in a state that looks like
I have mono but there's also some
likelihood associated with it that I
will be in some state that looks like I
have strep that's what happens when you
run the transition update when you run
the transition update you end up
accumulating all the probabilities
associated with being in a particular
new state as a consequence of being in a
particular previous state and entering
that new state based on the transition
distribution once you accumulate all
these values you end up with your new
distribution over new state
this represents one step of state
estimation if I wanted to run multiple I
would take the value that I got here for
s of T plus one replace it in the value
for s of T and run the same process of
Bayesian reasoning and transition update
this concludes my review of state
estimation next time we'll talk about
search